Nick Carter and wife Lauren are due to
welcome their first child on April 12th
et has the exclusive details as the
Backstreet Boy singer prepares for the
arrival of his little boy
you guys have any names picked out yeah
is the nursery done yeah we can't say
the names yet actually I've been
instructed by my wife to keep it a
little under wraps but we have a name is
it something sentimental put it this way
it's a very strong name and something
the first time parents gushed about each
other at the dead seven premiere
Saturday and revealed what they are
looking forward to most about Parenthood
and what are you guys most excited to
see in each other just this
unconditional love that he can give to
his son and the son can give to him the
family that we just always wanted
I don't want to get all sappy but snappy
she's the reason why I I felt
comfortable and because I knew that she
would be the perfect mother and she
would be able to help me teach our child
all the things that he needs to learn